INTERVIEWER 1: Interacting
with wild animals
is a popular touristy thing
to do all over the world.
You can feed monkeys
at a park in Japan.
You can ride
elephants in Thailand.
We actually did a
video on that one.
You can even feed parrots
in downtown San Francisco,
though the city really
doesn't want you to.
Taming wild animals
isn't always a good idea
but it's undeniably exciting.
It gets us up close and
personal with nature
in a way that's
usually fun and safe.
I say usually because there are
interactions like this and some
like this.
So this isn't quite as
harrowing as it looks,
but it still makes me nervous.
It's a picture from the city of
Harar, Ethiopia, a place where
people live in very close
proximity with hyenas.
And I do mean close.
JOSH SHEFMAN: Every
night, wild spotted hyenas
would sulk into the
city looking for food.
INTERVIEWER 1: That, by the way,
is the photographer Joshua Paul
Shefman.
JOSH SHEFMAN: At a designated
spot outside the ancient city
walls, a hyena man would
bring the pale meat
as tourists would gather
to watch, and most
shockingly, to participate
in a very intimate feeding.
INTERVIEWER 1: Joshua
is a travel photographer
based in Toronto.
And while he too was a little
freaked out by the scene,
like any photojournalist,
he had to get the shot.
JOSH SHEFMAN: Here, a
small child egged on
by his unabashedly eager
parents takes a slightly risky
opportunity to feed
these carnivores
as they prance back
and forth around him.
By the look on his face,
it was pretty obvious he
didn't feel too secure.
But who could
possibly blame him?
I thought the parents
irresponsible.
But at the same time,
I felt I had to capture
what was to come next.
INTERVIEWER 1: What came next,
the feeding of these hyenas,
actually has a bit
of history in Harar.
JOSH SHEFMAN: For
at least 50 years,
wild hyenas have been fed
by a farmer and his family
outside the gates of
these ancient walls, all
done apparently
to encourage them
to spare the city's livestock.
Today, this practice has become
a big tourist draw to Harar.
INTERVIEWER 1: The farmers
there are right to keep tabs
on their livestock.
Hyenas are often thought
of as dirty scavengers,
but that's not accurate.
95% of their food comes
from kills they make.
They're hunters.
And while hyena attacks
on humans are rare,
they do happen, which
makes it seem like this
all the more unnerving.
JOSH SHEFMAN: While
habituated to humans,
these were still very clearly
wild animals-- animals with one
of the strongest jaws
in the animal kingdom.
Nevertheless, the hyenas
were only interested
in the free meal.
INTERVIEWER 1:
Given all of that,
it's hard to know what
we're even looking at here.
Is this a tradition, a matter
of practicality, a tourist trap?
It might be all the above.
The fact is that
people and hyenas
have been sharing spaces
in this part of Africa
for a long, long time.
And that creates a complicated
relationship, albeit one
that makes for a more dramatic
picture than parrots eating out
of your hand.
If you're looking for
more that's happened here,
click now to check out this next
episode about an epic African
safari.
INTERVIEWER 2: But of course,
lounging in a pool and watching
impala was nothing
compared to what
Johan and Audrey saw on safari.
INTERVIEWER 1: And as always,
don't forget to subscribe.
Thanks for watching.